all right hello everyone welcome to
another episode of uh history of science
and technology q a
let's see we had a few questions saved
up but not so many so i looking forward
to questions about
anything about history of science and
technology
either things that you might think i've
been personally involved in or things
from longer ago you know i have to tell
you i just spent the last
couple of hours doing something very
seemingly unceo-like
uh debugging a piece of code
that along with a lot of other people
that is something which i've been
complaining about for like three years
that uh
uh there's a particular failure that's
happening when i do large-scale parallel
computations across hundreds of machines
and so on and it's like the occasional
failures and it's like what's going on
it is an interesting process debugging
code and maybe um
it's uh
we could talk a little bit about the
history of bugs
and why bugs happen and so on i think
the thing and maybe some of my
experiences of this i think that the um
you know the the name bug
originally came comes from i think it
was the anihac
in the late 1940s maybe
um early electronic computer
um
that
where
some failure happened
and um
it turned out there was a big machine
that filled the whole room and it turned
out the failure was a hardware failure
and the cause of the failure was a moth
that got into the um
uh into the machine and that was a bug
in the machine so to speak and hence the
name bug for some kind of error but of
course that was a hardware error what
we're now dealing with mostly are
software errors
um i have to say back in the day there
used to be uh i don't know 40 years ago
or something used to be much more common
for sort of hardware errors to be the
things that one thought about in terms
of machines i remember a vax 11780 was a
so-called mini computer which meant that
it wasn't the size of a whole room it
was only the size of a few giant file
cabin well many giant file cabinets
i remember that it used to have these
interrupt levels you know when machines
run they are trying to there are
different processors are trying to run
and the cpu is uh is being is that the
operating system is deciding which
process to run
and there can be these interrupt levels
where some
other thing can interrupt what's
happening and the thing of higher
interrupt level interrupt priority level
will get to run next maybe it's
something that comes in from input
output or some such other thing i do
remember on the vax that there was a i
think it was a level 13 priority
interrupt and the description of it was
the machine is on fire
uh that was uh the of course the
the goal was if the machine detected
that was on fire the most high priority
thing is to go shut down discs retract
heads from these spinning discs things
like that because in those days when one
talked about a disc i mean i remember
when we got these maybe a couple of
megabyte discs these were big things the
size of a washing machine and they're
big physical platters that were spinning
uh you know bit big things that were
like uh three feet across or something
or more that was spinning uh around they
usually discs i think have always spun
at about 60 hertz uh i think it's always
the the the speed that they spin at but
uh the amount of angular momentum in
something that is a a very big uh you
know three foot piece of metal um
is uh is quite something
but anyway the the um
uh the question
of um
uh what
uh so we're we're talking about kind of
the origin of bugs so you know the very
first what one can see is the very first
kind of proto program that anybody wrote
was what alan turing
wrote when he wrote his original paper
in 1936
that
originated the idea of the universal
turing machine the idea of the universal
turing machine being we can write down
this kind of idealization of how a
mechanical process for doing a
mathematical computation might work and
we can show that this particular kind of
hardware process is capable of emulating
any other turing machine of the same
type that was kind of alan turing's
original proof
it's a kind of hard to read paper
not least because the notation is quite
uh he's inventing a notation for a new
area that didn't really have notation
before he uses greek letters for some
things and as he put it in 1936 german
letters which means gothic type for
other kinds of things
and uh
he gives kind of a program for his
universal turing machine and that
program was riddled with bugs
he didn't have any idea that that was
sort of a thing that you know you would
write a program and you would imagine
this is a program that's going to run
but you wouldn't know to think oh i
might have made a mistake
and i suppose in the best model for that
type of thing would be theorem proving
in mathematics you know you write the
proof of a theorem did you make any
mistake or not well i'm quite certain
that the literature of mathematics and
many famous
proofs
are if you really micro look at them
will have bugs in them but you don't
know that because the consumers of those
proofs are just mere humans we're just
going to read them and say oh that's
okay that's okay it's all good i think
that the um
the thing that
but if you have a computer run that code
the computer is much less forgiving and
it will
notice that there's a bug you know when
it comes to sort of written documents
and things there's a question about dot
bugs in for example legal documents a
famous story which i believe to be a
true story
is when kurt godel was going to do his
citizenship interview in in princeton
well i think in trenton new jersey um he
uh it was a friend of albert einstein's
and um the two of them were going off
together to uh for cut girdle to go and
do his u.s citizenship interview
and kurt godel was noticing that he'd
read you know because he was going to
get quizzed on things about the u.s
constitution he'd read the u.s
constitution very carefully
and it had a bug
it was possible for the u.s to become a
dictatorship if this and this and this
happened and this person died and this
person whatever i don't know exactly
what the chain of events was einstein
convinced him not to not to bring that
up obviously kurt godel was at the time
coming from uh
a um uh
well i guess he'd he'd
grown up in
austria but at that point yeah he must
have been in vienna at that point um
he'd come from from uh
uh austria which had been taken over by
germany at that point
the um in any case the the thing that um
uh we're talking about bugs
and um
there's
kind of a long history of people not
really expecting bugs that that was
something which came up it snuck up
slowly on people
as programs got more complicated and as
people
uh kind of
got to the point where routinely there
would be very big programs
and i think
i'm trying to uh think about some
uh
other cases like like for example von
neumann
i think
had stated in the
uh probably the beginning of the 1950s
no program that anybody would ever
seriously want to write will be more
than i forget
200 400 lines long something like this
that was an interesting mistake
it was a mistake that i think came from
a failure to understand modularity and
code failure to understand that you
could have a sub function that you could
separately write and that might be you
know well normal would not be entirely
wrong that by the time you have a single
function that's more than a few hundred
lines long there's probably something
horribly wrong happening it's going to
be very hard to understand what's going
on because we humans tend to sort of
like to have bite-sized things to think
about we like to have kind of this is a
function that does this it's being
called by some function that does this
and this but but we want each sort of
piece as a sort of cognitive element
that's that's comparatively small and so
i think that was the
uh the thing that um
uh
that was sort of the cause of that
mistake was that a sort of a single
proof in mathematics probably wouldn't
be longer than that um and but there
might be in a sense sublemmas that might
go off to other papers and things that
bon and didn't really think of that idea
in terms of what computers might do i'm
not quite sure who invented the notion
of being able to call a sub function
because in order to do that you have to
have the notion of a stack for example
and i'm not sure when that notion came
into being i'm trying to think whether
the first computer that i used
didn't
explicitly have a stack i think i think
that was something that
got created later on i mean in in actual
computers like in a unix operating
system for instance
the the memory of the heap memory of
just sort of working memory it grows in
memory location sort of up from the
bottom of address space and the stack
which stores the information about how
to return from a function call um that
grows from the bottom from the top of
memory space
and back in the day i don't know if it's
still true the disaster that could
happen would be you'd use so much stack
space and so much heap space eventually
those addresses meet in the middle and
then that process is toast
but
in any case the this whole question of
uh
how
programs
what how one thinks about bugs and
programs
and kind of almost a calculus of bugs i
think we still don't have a good
calculus of bugs
it's still the case that
it
for example if we look at human medical
diagnosis you know there's a
well-classified collection of kinds of
things that can go wrong with us humans
there's no similar thing for bugs and
programs
and it's an anecdotal thing as you do
more programming that you learn
different kinds of things that go wrong
you know what about the end case
is there an off by one error you know
could you be writing outside of this
area of memory things like that
uh lots of modern systems certainly in
waltham language for example
the kind of scribbling on memory is
something that can't be done from but at
the user level and lots of modern
programming languages have various kinds
of protections against that but that's
just one of a sort of infinite number of
possible bugs the bug that uh we were
just looking at
is a bug that is deep inside into
process communication
and uh it was well i could describe what
was happening but um i think we just
found it actually and it's a bug in a
oh gosh i mean it was it was a bug where
you're launching 150
different sub processors
and out of those on one machine the
machine only produces 11 out of the 12
processors that it should be launching
and sometimes it's a different number if
you ask the machine to launch 60
processors it will be some random
collection of three processors that
won't launch those processors that don't
launch don't launch because oh boy we're
going to get super technical here
because
they are where they're they're they're
being connected to through ssh the
secure shell and then the secure shell
the process is calling back to its
parent through the secure shell and
somehow it's ending up in some kind of
weight state as it tries to call back to
the parent
and it's burning it's just it's just
looping in the cpu actually it's looping
partly in user space and partly in
system space
more in system space than user space
and anyway bottom line it's it's
probably
some bug in handling an edge case
of when something
just almost hit some time out
um and and some deep inside some piece
of code
but in any case the the um i mean i
could also talk a little bit about
famous bugs i mean it used to be the
case that there was a um
uh
uh kind of a news group alt dot risks or
something i i forget that kind of listed
some of the well-known bugs that have
happened in the history of of technology
and particularly computing and software
i mean a you know famous one there was
an uh
uh
missile um
an an
anti-shell missile thing that had a
famous bug where
it was um
it had a counter that was some kind of
timing counter and that time encounter
um
was
overran so it was a time encounter that
was like i don't know 32
maybe probably in those days 16-bit
counter was counting up every second and
if the system was turned on for too long
then it would end up uh uh the the the
the numbers it didn't have any
protection for whether that number got
too big to store in a 16-bit integer and
so it wrapped around and then all bets
were off and it did the wrong thing
but there are there are so many of these
stories there are a lot of stories of
things where there was a a
something that was a number for example
stored in a fixed size
uh
register and that register the number
got too big that's a pretty common
pretty common story um
and uh there were
there are a bunch of these i mean i
could rattle off a few others but
but um they're
uh they're things where
it's
one general category of bug is
the person just didn't think of that
corner case
they didn't sort of think about all the
possible things that could happen
and as one tries to sort of verify
programs sometimes one is able to think
about all the possible things that can
happen sometimes like the debugging we
were just doing which is a real-time
program that involves communication
between multiple machines and processes
and timing information and so on that's
not something where you can expect in
the normal way at least to just say run
that code
you know for example a very common kind
of issue in code is coverage analysis
like is there is it in fact the case
that you have a test that will actually
go down every branch of this code that's
a hard thing to do when for example in
in
debugging in quality assurance for
orphan language
we're able to do a lot of that but some
pieces are hard to do because some
pieces rely on things like real-time
interrupts did the person press this
button to stop things at this moment how
do you deal with that can you produce
something which will have coverage for
all of those sort of real-time
conditions
well anyway a little bit on that
uh there's a question here from
promenities asking did i ever meet andre
sacharov
what do i think of his cosmology i did
not meet andrei sakharov
he was some
uh
he wrote some
interesting papers
about
cosmology and about the origin of the
discrepancy between matter and
antimatter in the universe as i recall
it's been a long time those papers must
have been
in the late 1960s probably
and they were
papers that
will have been relevant to work that i
was doing in the late 1970s
one of the big questions i was
interested in
back
oh when i was a kid
mid-1970s
was
one knows about mata and antimatter
protons antiprotons electrons positrons
and so on
right around here
everything we're dealing with the earth
the sun whatever it's all made of matter
one would think from sort of the
symmetry of things that there will be
about as much antimatter in the universe
as mata
but
and so how could that be you know is
that could that be the case for example
as we look out of the andromeda galaxy
could it be an anti-galaxy could it be
made of antimatter where in the universe
could there be mata versus antimatter
and i remember back in 1976
that was very much a question and i
remember trying to figure out if there
were parts of the universe that were
made of mata and other parts that were
made of antimatter there would be some
region in between them where there would
be uh annihilation of matter and
antimatter and one of the things that
could happen is this leidenfrost
phenomenon where kind of when things are
kind of boiling and they're producing
vapor that's producing pressure that's
holding apart these things that would
otherwise be boiling so to speak and the
same kind of thing would happen with
matter and antimatter those things might
be let's say gravitationally attracted
to each other but at the boundary where
matter and antimatter are annihilating
lots of energy will be being produced
and that will produce radiation pressure
which will potentially hold the matter
antimatter apart so i was interested in
could that actually could it be the case
that there was antimatter uh galaxies in
the universe but there was just so
little matter between galaxies in
intergalactic space there's maybe one
hydrogen atom per cubic meter for
example was that sufficiently little
that there just wouldn't be
very much annihilation radiation which
would be visible in gamma ray
astronomy and things like that you
should be able to see annihilation
radiation if there was any um would
there be uh annihilation radiation
that um
uh
uh would be would reveal the fact that
parts of the universe were made of
matter and parts of antimatter it's a
big question if you just see light from
a star how can you tell whether it's a
light from a star or from an anti-star
and it's a pretty subtle thing
the there is a there are some ways to
tell
using
uh well essentially using circular
polarization of light um and that that
happens because one of the features of
uh
the turns out that charge conjugation
the symmetry from mata to antimatter is
not a perfect symmetry of the universe
it's uh it is violated by weak
interactions
and one feature of it is a consequence
for neutrinos that a neutrino is always
left-handed it always spins in such a
way that its spin direction is sort of
left-handed rule relative to its
direction of motion anti-neutrinos are
right-handed if there was perfect charge
conjugation symmetry both neutrinos and
anti-neutrinos would have sort of the
same handedness so the
same handedness so there's ways to uh
potentially i haven't looked at this in
in 40 years probably there's ways that
one can expect that in various kinds of
nuclear beta decay where neutrinos are
involved that there would be photons
that would also be produced that would
have different left and right circular
polarization and you might be able to
detect that from stars and see whether
oh in that supernova was it a supernova
or an anti-supernova
anyway the thing that as i recall
um
was was then a question
uh well it's a question i was interested
in 1976 and so on how could one
understand the mata versus antimatter
story for the universe and i think it
was an idea of sakharov's and and other
people were involved by this point
that
if there was
a violation of um
uh if that well that
you could get
let's see i mean i worked on this quite
extensively so the the the question was
in the very early universe the
interaction between the expansion of the
universe and the small effects of charge
conjugation violation actually it had to
be so-called cp violation
um violation of charge conjugation and
parity together small cp violation
effects in an expanding universe
where the expanding universe effectively
has defined a time direction
that those effects
could lead to a difference in the amount
of matter and antimatter and i i seem to
recall there were papers of andrei
sakharov's from the 1960s about related
kinds of things
and i think that the um
uh the question
that came out there
was it turns out if you have a particle
and an antiparticle let's say
a i don't know a a a k on and an anti k
on
uh they have the same lifetime the total
lifetime total decay uh the the
half-life of those particles is the same
but the partial decay rates
of let's say
a um
i don't know a k plus
going to a pi plus and a pi zero
versus
a k plus bar that's a k minus going to a
pi minus and a pi zero those partial
rates
are allowed to be different according to
cpt invariance which is something we
believe to be a general symmetry of
quantum field theories
and
that was uh i mean i can talk a little
bit about the history gosh there's lots
of history lots of interesting history
there um about what we can talk about
let's talk about the history of
antimatter for a minute
um
the
uh
antimatter really quite an interesting
history nobody imagined it would be
there
until
1930s when paul dirac
a physicist in cambridge a very
mathematically oriented physicist
um
was uh
uh tried to figure out
the
so-called wave equation
for a relativistic particle like an
electron that was capable of going close
to the speed of light
prior to that in the early days of
quantum mechanics in 1920s this thing
called the schrodinger equation which is
the equation for the
the so-called wave function essentially
quantum amplitude of
quantum mechanical stuff
which eventually the the mod squared of
it gives you a probabilities according
to the standard interpretation of
quantum mechanics
that
idea
um
uh the the so the schrodinger equation
was an equation good for
non-relativistic particles it's the
thing that's used all the time today in
studying lots of quantum effects in
chemistry and elsewhere but one wanted
an equation which was consistent with uh
relativity the schrodinger equation is
an equation which has uh uh it's like a
diffusion equation it's first order in
time first order time derivative and
it's second order in space so it's not
treating space and time kind of
symmetrically there and so the question
was
was there a a similar equation for
relativistic particles there was a thing
called the kine gordon equation which
was good for spin zero particles
um that were and there was also
uh an equation for the electromagnetic
field which is a spin one particle but
the real question was what about
electrons that were kind of spin half
particles what would be their
relativistic wave equation and that's
what paul dirac worked out he kind of
had this idea which sort of a weird idea
that the the differential operator that
appears in the equations for spin zero
and has been one and so on you can take
kind of the square root of that operator
and you get this kind of thing which is
a linear um
linear
uh differential operator together with
these so-called dirac gamma matrices and
it's all a little bit complicated but
one feature of sort of taking the square
root is that there was a positive square
root it's like when you take the square
root of one or something you get plus
one and minus one and that's what
happened in the dirac equation you got
both the positive square root and the
negative square root so to speak and
then the question was what did those
negative square roots mean
because they were things like an
electron but they were things that had
negative energy
and so the question was what would be
the interpretation of that
now it was known by that point the pauli
exclusion principle was known that's the
idea that when you have a spin a half
particle for example you can't ever have
two spinner hard particles in exactly
the same state
they will be excluded from being in the
same state that was a wolfgang paulie
idea from the 1920s
and it was
a um
it was something where
uh i think we actually slowly beginning
to understand in our model of physics
what is the origin of the exclusion
principle and the idea of fermions and
so on but putting that aside at that
time it was known that you would kind of
if you had a bunch of energy levels for
electrons you could like fill them up
just as you do in chemistry with shells
for electrons and atoms and so on you
could fill them up and at that point you
would and so what dirac imagined was
that there was the sea
of of uh electron energy levels that
were all negative energy and you filled
them all up but you could have a hole in
that sea of negative energy electrons
and that the question is what would that
hole be like and you realize that hole
be like an anti-electron be like
something with a with a charge that was
uh plus one instead of the minus one
charge of the electron but it would have
positive mass
and so he kind of said well there should
be this thing the anti-electron the
positron antimatter so it was something
that came out of in a sense the
mathematical setup and elegance
of what was going on that there should
be anti-particles
so then people wondered well are there
actually anti-particles
uh that
the main place to see particles at that
time as cosmic rays there's a flux of
particles mostly from the the lowest
energy ones are from the sun there are
much higher energy ones from from much
further away but they hit the upper
atmosphere of the earth
and mostly it's protons um mostly the
protons interact in the upper levels of
the atmosphere and by the time you're at
sea level it's mostly muons
but people had taken emulsion stacks
onto mountains
um
they were particularly was a group in
bristol in england um it was doing this
a lot
where
they would have so what was an emulsion
stack at the time uh okay you have a
photographic uh plate
um that is a photographic emulsion it's
a a um
it has the feature that when a photon of
light hits the silver bromide
um molecule it the silver gets ejected
and that silver is what you can develop
to then show oh that's a black part on
the on the on the film so to speak
and so the idea was
that a photon coming through
actually any particle any energetic
particle that might hit that molecule
would eject the silver atom and
produce something which was as if light
had fallen on that part of the
photographic plate but the idea was to
have an emulsion stack we just had a big
chunk of uh of this kind of emulsion
silver bromide or whatever else
and you would end up if a particle went
through the particle would be would be
sort of
ejecting silver atoms all the way
through so you get this whole track
where the where the particle would would
go through
and that
and what people would do is they take
this emulsion stack they would take it
on a mountain they would have all these
cosmic rays go through it then they
would take it apart and people would
painstakingly go through with a
microscope and look for little little uh
lines of tracks where particles would go
through i might say just a few sort of
more personal things about this i mean
buldarak
was i never met paul dirac i i could
easily have met him but i didn't
unfortunately
uh my friend richard feynman certainly
did meet him
he always described buldarak as
monosyllabic
he said that he just would barely ever
say anything
and um uh the i gather that pulverak
spent most of his career in cambridge
england
and finally at sort of the then
mandatory retirement age of probably 60
or something he moved to florida
and apparently became a much more social
kind of
kind of character there and somehow the
the cambridge atmosphere had caused him
to be the one to be uh
in this very um monosyllabic kind of
mode of uh
sort of almost um
uh a very closed kind of um answering
questions only with with one word and so
on
um i think that um dirac
had was a very kind of
a mathematical thinker uh much more
mathematical and meant more sort of uh
cleanly mathematical than most of the
physicists of the time
and he wrote a book uh was a well-known
book about principles of quantum
mechanics which introduced many of the
notations that we use in quantum
mechanics the bra and cat no captain
it's kind of a cute little thing that's
the angle bracket one way and angle
bracket the other way and dirac called
that a bra and a ket because the whole
thing would be a bracket with a c in the
middle but the left-hand side was a bra
and the right-hand side was a ket
so
the um
in any case then um
uh
well emulsion stacks
when um
when i was uh
a student in oxford in the
what 1976 1977 time frame it was still
the case that there would be
this area where people would be going
through these um actually by that time
it was bubble chamber uh pictures but i
think they may also have had some
emulsion pictures at that time looking
for particle tracks
and they would have a whole set up
they'd project an image of the thing on
a big table and they would be have you
know rulers and things they'd be
measuring stuff and it's like oh yeah we
saw a you know there's a lambda particle
there it's an inch-long track from a
lambda particle
or there's a listen to that and and then
recording what they saw and that was
kind of still a thing people were
experimenting at that time with various
uh kind of image processing algorithms
um and so on but it was still very much
a manual activity
of uh of people actually um uh going
through and and doing this kind of
manual reading of emulsions and and by
that time bubble chamber pictures
but anyway back in the uh
1930s
the thing people started uh looking for
these um
uh
uh looking for the the source of high
energy particles was cosmic rays and
people looked for
the um
people looked to see what kinds of
particles would be produced was it
always protons was it other things
and i think carl anderson was the person
who discovered the positron um
in uh it was kind of three things were
discovered roughly at the same time the
muon the uh the pion and the positron
they've been a
a uh prediction i guess 1937
what was it 36 ish something like that
hideki yokawa
in japan
had been working on the question of how
nuclei are held together and had come up
with this idea of pion exchange that
there was a particle uh about a tenth
the the mass of the proton that would be
being exchanged back and forth between
protons in the nucleus of of uh of atoms
and that that was the sort of a carrier
particle for the strong nuclear force
and people kind of wanted to look for
that
and started looking for it in cosmic
rays
they thought they found it
but they actually had found the muon
which is a particle where nobody knows
why it exists just like an electron but
206 roughly times heavier than the
electron and it's sort of a big mystery
that maybe maybe we'll have a chance to
clear up as we probe more into our
fundamental theory of physics uh why the
muon and the thing called the tau lepton
which is another thing just like a heavy
electron exists but that was the thing
that got discovered first then the pion
got discovered and somewhere in the
middle of that the positron got
discovered as an actual uh particle that
um uh as an actual example of antimatter
and um
the antiproton got discovered somewhat
after that time um i think that required
uh i'm trying to remember whether that
was discovered in cosmic rays whether
that was discovered in early particle
accelerators see what happened with
particle accelerators
is that
you are basically going to use
electrical magnetic forces to make
particles go very fast the initial way
of doing that was on a cyclotron a
circular device where you would have
these kind of electromagnetic waves that
would like push particles to go faster
um around the circle
there were
that was something was developed some i
think as a result of radar technology
that had developed in world war ii where
the concept of a a
radar tube the the idea of of being able
to control electromagnetic radiation to
have a cavity where you could excite
certain modes of the electromagnetic
field and then shoot them out in some
direction for radar the the um those
kinds of amplifiers and things like
klaystrons and so on were
um
uh
i'm trying to remember all this history
the um
that was the thing that had been
was it was kind of the first big
sort of technical thing that um in
silicon valley varian associates was a
microwave company that came out just
after world war ii i think um and but
somehow lawrence berkeley lab which was
kind of um
uh uh sort of there were there were many
spin-offs from the manhattan project and
many kinds of additional pieces of big
physics that got started as a result of
that and one of the main beneficiaries
was this idea of okay now we understand
something about nuclear physics let's go
on and try and understand subnuclear
physics um that was what
particle physics was originally called
was subnuclear uh people talked about
subnuclear particles and so on um and
particles that were uh sort of beyond
the level of a whole nucleus you know
the what what could be what could exist
in a nucleus and the the first particle
accelerators were built in the 1940s
and uh
that that was some
kind of when a whole bunch of other
particles started to get discovered in
the 1950s well there'd been a sequence
of particles discovered everyone had a
discovery story you know i think the
lambda particle that's uh the thing
that's kind of like a proton but
eventually was uh the strange first
strange particle where the mass protons
mass is 938 million electron volts
and the lambda particle has a mass of
about 1.15 million electron volts those
are
for somebody like me who was a particle
physics enthusiast when they were a kid
these are famous numbers so to speak
and then there were other particles
discovered the the sigma particles they
have one three eight five mev if i
remember correctly the the um uh then
the so-called cascade hyperons which are
called cascade hyperons because they
decay into sigma particles and the sigma
particles decay into protons
and then
one of the things that was sort of a
question was okay there's this whole zoo
of particles that were being discovered
particularly in the late 1950s early
1960s sort of how did this all fit
together and there were two main things
that came out of that one was the thing
called reggie theory and another was the
so-called eightfold way and the quark
model
and i think that the um
the thing that uh well the the idea of
uh reggie trajectories had to do with
well you would have a particle that had
a certain spin like zero another one
with spin one another one with spin two
there would be this whole series of
particles that
were
of increasing spins
and they would be a series from the pion
with a mass of 134 mev to the row
particle with a mass of uh 770 mev to
the f particle the row particles spin
one to the f particle with a mass of
1270 mev at least it used to i think it
may have moved since then uh moved as
and the experiments got better and that
was a spin two particle and you could
kind of plot these lines whereas a as
you increase the spin of the particle
the mass would be correspondingly
increased and that was uh sort of
identified as these kind of uh flights
of particles and the idea due to talia
reggie and again somebody i've
fortunately never met um
uh was kind of a creative idea of
usually the spin of a particle was
thought in in basic quantum mechanics to
be an integer or half integer he said
well what if it's a complex number what
if it's an arbitrary complex number can
we think about kind of what this
continuous
thing as a function of complex
angular momentum would be like
and that thinking eventually led to
string theory
that was kind of the mathematical
underpinning of string theory but so
that was one branch was kind of the regi
trajectories idea for these flights of
particles the other branch had to do
with understanding
what
uh why there were protons and lambda
particles and sigma particles and side
particles and so on and that was what
led to the quark model the idea that you
could actually sort of break those
particles down into sub components it's
a little bit like what people like
dalton had done
in the 1800s thinking about atoms and
kinds of chemical elements
of thinking you know could you well
first of all breaking down molecules
into constituent atoms and saying
they're made from a discrete set of
elements and then later thinking about
well these chemical elements what's what
what is different between these chemical
elements
oh eventually and this became clear in
the early 1900s eventually it's like you
know mendeleev had organized the
chemical elements in this kind of
empirical way into the periodic table
and had sort of assigned numbers to
these things and so on and it became
clear that what those numbers
corresponded to was the number of the
protons and electrons
in the atoms of these particular
elements
but so sort of that was being retried
for particle physics of could you by the
time you had you know there was the
thing called the particle data table was
one of my favorite books when i was a
kid like the little kind of pocket uh
sort of um a
very convenient kind of a pocket
guide to the particles of our universe
so to speak and it started off with a um
a guy called uh his first name um
rosenfeld was his last name often called
the rosenfeld tables i think rosenfeld
went off to go into the electric power
industry at some point but um in the
early days in the 1950s this was the
thing i think it's still maintained at
lawrence berkeley lab the particle data
group
maintains the particle data table it was
from berkeley and cern i think
um but anyway when i was a kid i used to
get these things i i had the i certainly
had the 1973 edition that must have been
when i was 13 or so of the particle data
table there's a very convenient carry it
around everywhere little booklets um but
um the uh that that little booklet had
started off as a kind of one sheet of
paper um of of these tables but as more
and more particles got discovered there
were eventually hundreds of particles
and the question was how what how could
one explain all of these
and
sort of the first big break in this was
due to murray gilman in 1955-ish
inventing this idea of what he called
strangeness
and the notion was there were particles
and they had electric charges and and
etc but maybe there was another quantum
number another kind of thing like
electric charge that would be
characteristic particles and for example
the aforementioned lambda particle might
have a strangeness um as and that would
be the thing that um would distinguish
it from just a being a pure proton and
so this idea of strangeness and there
were a lot of phenomena there was a
thing called associated production where
in a
in a nuclear strong interaction
you would only get a strange particle
and an anti-strange particle produced
together you couldn't get a single
strange particle produced but then the
weak interaction could produce single
strange particles so the weak
interaction was strangeness violating
the strong interaction was not and this
was kind of the idea of this strangeness
quantum number that was assigned to
certain particles and so then the
question really was
how did that
could you then do things like
where did the strangeness idea come from
where where was what was the underlying
thing that led some particles to have
different strangeness and others and so
on
well i don't know the full history of
this and i know the people involved and
i still don't know the full history the
um uh murray girl man this is
1963 i think
uh
was i i knew murray garman quite well um
he um
he was by the time i mean i i first knew
him in
probably first talked to him in 1976.
so quite a few years after the time
we're talking about here um but he was i
think always somebody who liked to have
he's very erudite
scientist in many ways he liked to learn
human languages and things like that he
also liked to learn kind of mathematical
techniques
and one of the mathematical techniques
that he was kind of keen on was group
theory
and so he kind of tried to take the sort
of idea of strangeness and wrap around
it a bunch of things about the theory of
lead groups and a lot of other sort of
elaborate mathematical theories
and
out of that came
kind of a notion that
oh there must be
some sort of collection of particles
that were somehow related by some kind
of rotation not in physical space but in
this abstract su-3
uh sort of strangeness-ish space
i would now be called sort of flavor
space
but anyway so get this idea um meanwhile
there was a person who was then a
graduate student somebody i've known
quite well for many years named george
zweig who was a graduate student at
caltech
who
i think did something much
less highfalutin so to speak
just looked at all these particles and
said if you did the same kind of thing
that had been done you know for
chemistry for nuclear physics of just
saying how would you if you just said
you know if this if there were these
components that were inside particles
what kinds of components would have to
exist to get the particles we know
and so he called those components aces i
don't quite know why i've never asked
him um but uh he
then
was uh
he did that he was actually by then i
think visiting cern
and murray gilman also at caltech
used the sort of highfalutin group
theory stuff but ended up with sort of
this idea about this sort of collection
of what particles must exist
and sort of by implication
ended up with this notion that well you
could think about that as the generators
of this group would be quarks
now what were these quarks were they
actual particles that you could see
or were they just
uh kind of um mathematical concepts
and george zweig took the point of view
that they really were physical particles
that you could see and actually for many
years when i first knew him in the in
the 1970s he was very intent on trying
to search for kind of the the
consequences of there just being quarks
out there in the world
now one of the mysteries was okay you
say there should be a quark that is a
constituent of a proton but the quark
would have to have a charge of one-third
of a unit of electron charge
and people said but charges somehow
quantized we don't quite know why people
still don't know why charge is quantized
actually dirac had had an argument for
why charge was quantity would be
quantized if there existed just one
magnetic monopole in the universe
charge would have to be quantized but so
far we don't we don't think any one of
those exists so that argument doesn't
really quite work but so people didn't
know why charge was quantized but it was
it was observed to be quantized and the
idea that there should be a particle
with one third integer charge was a very
shocking idea and more than that people
said but look we've never seen a
particle with one third integer charge
you know in no particle experiment
particle physics experiment or anything
has that ever been seen
and so that was sort of a mysterious
thing and people said well maybe if we
have a bigger particle accelerator will
be able just like we were able to break
nuclei up into their constituent
nucleons protons and neutrons and so on
so similarly if we hit a proton hard
enough it's just going to shatter into a
bunch of porps
and it had three primary quarks that it
should be made of maybe it'll just sort
of shatter into those quarks
but people didn't find that and so it
sort of became quite a mysterious thing
how could quarks exist what really were
they were they just mathematical were
they really things that existed what was
the story behind that
but
from sort of the the group theory angle
of well if you just thought about these
rotations and these quarks were
generators of rotations and so on and so
on and so on whether they exist as
physical things or not
then the implication was that you could
uh get
a um
uh that there was there was something
that had to be true there had to be
another particle there was the thing
called there were these different groups
of particles there was a thing called
the octet of eight particles needless to
say and there was a thing called the
decouplet of ten particles but only nine
of those ten particles were known there
was one missing a strangeness minus
three particle that was at the if you
drew out the way that these um these
so-called multiplets you could draw them
out as a function of um of uh well think
of isospin and and hypercharge which is
like strangeness and you could draw it
out and there would be at the peak of
this triangle there was something
missing and so murray garman made this
prediction that
uh there should be a particle there he
called it the omega minus capital omega
minus
and um it should have roughly a mass i
think 17
1675 mev something like that because you
could work out that was sort of a mass
formula that uh which in the end comes
out about because the strange quark has
a different mass from the other quarks
and so that leads to different masses of
particles that contain strange quarks
the omega minus
as we now know is a particle made from
three strange quarks
anyway in
1965 maybe six
sometime around then
um
the uh the omega minus was discovered in
a bubble chamber at brookhaven national
lab on long island
new york uh by a guy called nick samuels
i think um
and you know you see it as a little
track in this there's there's an omega
minus and it decays into a
psi particle a cascade hyper arm which
then decays into a lambda particle or a
sigma particle which then decays into a
proton and you see all that happening in
this in this bubble chamber picture um
just little little tracks and every time
there's a the most of the tracks are
straight and then they maybe break up in
two and then every so often there's this
curlicue kind of spirally track that's
an electron electron kind of spiraling
spiraling to rest as it keeps on hitting
other atoms in the in the bubble chamber
so in any case that was a big triumph
it's always exciting when a theory makes
a kind of a slightly unexpected
prediction people go out and look for it
and then they find it and nail it i'm
kind of hoping that's what's going to
happen with our fundamental theory of
physics we've got a number of leads on
possible kinds of things but it's always
a it's it's usually it's a lot of work
to go from the fundamental theory to an
actual prediction where somebody can go
you know measure something with a
particle accelerator or a telescope or
some such other thing anyway the omega
minus the sort of big triumph and it's
like yes this quark theory is right uh
murray had called it the eight-fold way
because it had this this uh octet this
eight particle combination and uh that
was sort of in in uh in reference to
buddhas and uh buddhism and the
eightfold way there i think that was a
kind of a piece of error edition that i
don't think really had i don't think it
was much buddhist about the whole thing
another person who'd been involved in
that was a person who worked with with
murray named yuval nehman who i met only
a couple of times
who was uh
um
a high-ranking
uh politician in israel actually who had
been very much involved in this
eightfold way creation in the early
1960s but any case the the um
the thing that then happened with
respect to quarks
is george vig was convinced that there
would be physical quarks somewhere that
somewhere in some chemical process
somewhere in the formation of the earth
somewhere in some high-energy cosmic ray
somewhere there would be quarks and he
spent a lot of time doing rather
interesting work on sort of the
chemistry of one-third integer charged
particles where would they go you know
would they wind up in sea water would
they wind up in this place in that place
but no quark was ever found no free
quark was ever found and then qcd
quantum chromodynamics came along and
people got this idea that maybe corks
were confined maybe there were forces
these these qcd gluon exchange forces
that between quarks and uh that were but
we're just keeping it confined so that
actually what happens is well maybe i
shouldn't go into this in more detail
but when you when you try and pull two
quarks apart
if you have electrical forces between
things the kind of lines of electric
force kind of go out like like a
hedgehog so to speak from each particle
and the number of lines of electric
force that intersect when the particles
get further apart get smaller and
smaller and that's why you have the
inverse square law for electrical
attraction but in the case of qcd
because gluons interact with themselves
in a way that photons don't those lines
of sort of flux of qcd flux of color
charge flux
those lines of flux attract each other
and so instead of having something where
it looks kind of like a hedgehog of
lines of flux you have something where
all those lines of flux get pulled
together into this kind of string
between the quarks and so as you pull
the quarks further apart that that sort
of string gets tighter and tighter
there's more flux there more energy has
to be expended that's kind of the
qualitative picture for why quarks are
confined now we don't actually know from
a mathematical point of view nobody's
proved that in qcd quarks have to be
confined it's a difficult problem in
quantum field theory that uh has been
sitting unsolved for the last well since
1973 when qcd was developed but in any
case the the other thing that happened
this must have been 1970 i think
was um
that people were just
kicking protons really hard with
electrons particularly at the stanford
linear accelerator center there were was
possible that was accelerating electrons
to high energies and uh just shooting
them into a target with i don't know
what had
you know protons in it and they would
find that most of the time
uh the electrons would just go straight
sort of they wouldn't be it wouldn't be
like they were hitting a hard thing they
would just go kind of keep going in the
same direction it's kind of like when
rutherford was doing rutherford
scattering back in the early 1900s most
of the time when he would kind of uh
shoot an alpha particle near an atom or
something most of the time would just
keep going straight through because most
of an atom is empty space and so most of
the time the the the thing that was
being shot at at the um at the atom
would just go through the empty space
and just keep going but occasionally
what rutherford found was well
occasionally it hit a hard bit and that
was the nucleus which is you know one
hundred thousandth of the radius of an
atom it would hit the hard bit in the
middle and bounce back uh sort of the
way it came or closer to the way it came
well the same exact thing was found with
electrons in protons that most of the
time they just sort of go straight
through but just sometimes they would
hit something it seemed like a hard bit
and they would kind of bounce back
and this question of well how do you
characterize that process
there was a
um
you could kind of characterize the
momentum transfer which was sort of how
much momentum was transferred from the
potential hard bit to the thing that was
coming in and so on and there was a
whole um uh there was a whole um
a whole story of that a person called
jim
was who was at slack
at stanford was a was a big figure in
that whole story um but then
the the person who really
pushed this in the end was was richard
feynman dick fineman um who came up with
this thing he called the pot on model
and the part-time model was kind of a a
nose thumb at murray gilman because he
was saying well there are hard bits
inside protons and we're going to call
them part-ons now people strongly
suspected that if there were hard bits
inside protons they were actually quarks
but that wasn't known for sure and and
dick feynman kind of decided he wasn't
going to give murray sort of the benefit
of the doubt this is these are part-ons
they may or may not be quarks and i
think murray was actually was was very
nervous about the idea that quarks had
some physical existence because people
were sort of telling him oh you know
they're always confined how can you
consider them as particles that's not
really a particle our definitions of
particle hood don't cover things that
are always confined so you know it's
just a mathematical construct i think he
was perfectly okay having them be
thought of as things that were kind of
just mathematical and didn't have some
instantiation where you could shoot an
electron at them and it would bounce
back
but um i remember
nick clement telling me he gave a talk i
think 1971 maybe sometime like that a
little bit before when i knew him um at
stanford
where he sort of introduced the spot on
model and he told me he'd kind of stayed
up all night the night before he'd got
all this experimental data and he was
trying to figure out how could you
explain this data or you can explain it
if there were these hard bits inside
protons
and
then he kind of gave this talk which was
this kind of famous talk
of uh kind of just sort of the the
outline of how this part-time model
would work
well
i i asked him you know did you actually
you know there's a certain intuition
about how this would how things would
work with hard bits inside protons et
cetera et cetera et cetera it's like how
did you know that this sort of these
pieces of intuition would be right and
other pieces of intuition wouldn't come
and sort of bite you with different
effects
well he said well of course he worked
out some whole toy model with one of
field theory um and uh but he didn't
tell anybody about that this was very
typical dick fineman you know he'd do a
lot of very elaborate calculation but he
thought that was kind of the easy part
wasn't easy for other people but it was
easy for him and so he kind of threw
that away and instead gave this sort of
very beautiful intuitive description of
kind of a little bit like the one i
tried to give you here um about kind of
hard bits and protons and so on and what
consequences that would have from
experiments and for years afterwards
people were like but how does this work
in terms of quantum field theory people
were trying to figure this out but that
was something that that uh dick feinman
had already figured out before he even
first presented this this idea but i
think he i'm not sure he ever published
any of that stuff
um by the time i knew him this 1976 70s
70 yeah 77 i guess
um
maybe even 78
uh
the um
uh he was actually pretty interested in
in sort of uh looking at
what were
then called um
part on showers maybe actually i called
them that i'm not sure if that might not
even be my name for them they were
things which in a high energy collision
you would get sometimes a whole uh what
would now be called jet of particles
produced in some direction in a high
energy collision and there was sort of
the what happens when you when you hit a
court card and it kind of gets
pushed out of the proton it was in it
goes off in some direction but it can't
be separated as a cork so it has to kind
of drag other particles it has to
produce other particles off in that
direction and that's what leads to these
jets of particles which uh i spent a
bunch of time studying and dick feynman
was also interested in studying back in
the late 1970s
much to the chagrin of people like
murray galman
who was saying because it was kind of a
messy business and it involved you know
what were then fortran programs things
like that of actually working out you
know oh there were going to be 50
particles produced you know what's the
chance that there'd be a bunch of pions
and this and that and the other it was
kind of messy and murray was always like
uh you know saying to to dick feynman
you know why are you working on all this
messy stuff murray would say to me why
are you working on this messy stuff you
know it's it's just very inelegant and
so on it was kind of i think in those
days it was sort of methodologically a
bit different because it involved a
bunch of computer simulation monte carlo
simulation of sort of let's generate a
whole bunch of events at random particle
events at random and then make sort of
aggregate curves of what the typical
behavior is that was something which was
a little bit of a a i would say a i mean
that the monte carlo method had been
invented
um
during world war ii for studying uh
neutron effects in in uh in nuclear
reactions but the um uh this sort of
application of it on on to particle
physics i think i i'm kind of thinking i
think that was kind of new at the time
um it was sort of an obvious thing to do
i have to say to my great chagrin
uh
i
was quite at that point already quite
decently sophisticated in kind of a
theory of computation and uh and sort of
what would later be called software
engineering and so on um but i didn't
write the actual code that we used to do
a bunch of these simulations of um of of
particle jets and so on and uh pretty
arbitrary set of like numbers for a pion
is a 17 or something a k on as an 18
because these things all had to be
translated into fortran code um because
that was the language that was being
used at that time and i do believe that
that crazy set of numbers that were sort
of very arbitrarily assigned have ended
up becoming the the standard that are
still used today in jet simulation
programs to compute you know events at
the lhc and things like this and it's a
little bit embarrassing in a sense that
um uh
i didn't um get more involved in that
and um uh
kind of try and use what i've spent kind
of a lifetime now honing i've sort of
designed software design and making sure
that oh there's a very systematic way to
number these things etc etc etc anyway
sorry about that
well
um
let's see that was a very long answer to
to that question
um
wow let me see
uh
there's some questions here right
there's a few simple ones here which
maybe i can can talk about
um erin asks how do i first meet nassim
to lab
and
why do i think he was able to take
a computational approach to finance
instead of reasoning by analogy it's an
interesting question i first met him i
remember it was rather i met him in the
lobby of some hotel in new york city
long before he was kind of started
writing books and things like that he
was a trader um at the time and i met
him through a a
friend of mine who's uh in the quant
quantitative finance business and he was
uh as he has always been a colorful
character and i remember him um uh
making
all sorts of um
uh wonderfully kind of snarky and
unexpected comments about all sorts of
things
it must have been
20 years ago something like that roughly
sometime like that
um and
i don't really know i i think nassim has
used sort of
uh
sort of mathematical computation a lot
usually using well from language and
mathematica and so on um
and i'm not sure he's been as much into
the kind of heavy duty computation
as most of the quantitative you know the
the big quantitative hedge fund folks
the you know the renaissance the the de
shore and company the um uh now two
sigma things like this these are all
outfits that have uh
in different ways kind of um found ways
to
use computation to kind of uh uh predict
things about the market and so on i mean
it always used to be the case you know
all these places are i'm happy to say
big users of our technology um it's one
of these things where everybody has
their their secret methods for beating
the market and i don't know what they
are so so i can't i can't tell you and
spill any secrets um but uh my
impression is that everybody has sort of
different you know one firm will be
using regression analysis it's just all
a giant regression analysis and another
firm will be using you know
computational geometry it's all about
that kind of thing another firm will be
using some other kind of technique um i
i you know people kept on saying this
machine learning is going to take over i
don't think that's quite happened i mean
people have been using sort of well
people have used neural nets for a long
time in finance um people had these
periods when it was like it's going to
be chaos theory it's going to be
fractals it's going to be transfinite
numbers that was that was a weird one
associated with high frequency trading
um but i don't think there's i think
it's one of these things
where
it's a continual kind of
race
and sort of any technique that gets you
a little advantage is interesting
um but in any case i think i think
nassim has been much more on the
thinking about kind of tales of
distributions in a way that sort of
mixes mathematical ideas
with
kind of everyday intuitional ideas and
sort of a mixture interesting mixture of
you know usually investing is divided
into this kind of uh
you know fundamentals versus more
technical where fundamentals is kind of
like i actually want to meet the people
who run that company and i'm actually
going to have a theory about what the
company does
versus the more technical side which is
i'm looking at all these numbers and all
i know about that company is it's ticker
symbol i haven't a clue what it actually
does and i don't really care all i know
is that it's you know it's it's kurtosis
of its you know its volatility of its
stock price has this and it's got a tail
that does that and so on and the fact
that it makes bricks for a living is
absolutely irrelevant all i care about
is the fact that it has this kind of
volatility every spring or something
and so so i think that those are
i think nassim is sort of in the middle
of those two with a with a kind of
intuition informed by mathematical ideas
um but i think a quite fundamental
approach to thinking about economics in
the market and so on
um
all right maybe one
more thing and then i should um
wrap up here
um
well there's a question here from aaron
how does the log for shell
vulnerability compare to other
historically significant web
vulnerabilities
um does the internet tend to change
course after large vulnerabilities
i would say the basic answer to
well okay so the history of of internet
vulnerabilities
is
uh an interesting one again it was
something people kind of
okay i remember
this must have been
1970 maybe
when i was pretty young hearing about
some of the first computer exploits and
i think they were down at mit
and i think the idea was the following
you got a password screen it said type
in your password that was a passwords
were already an idea then
and the
probably it was a password screen i'm
thinking it might have been some kind of
other input field
but then the basic notion was well what
if you just type a bunch of garbage in
there what if you just keep typing and
you keep you know putting in characters
and it way overflows the expected length
of that input field
and
turns out that kind of vulnerability
they're still with us today people still
make this mistake today they'll have
something where you expect a certain
amount of data to be put into this field
and actually you when you if you stuff
more data in there some of the data will
get stored in memory in a place where it
shouldn't have been stored it'll
overwrite something else and pretty soon
the program will have escaped and
started doing things i think the thing
to understand about computer security in
general is the following thing
in so far the goal in computer security
and modern computer security is get a
program to do something it wasn't
intended to do and eventually get that
program to go and sort of reach into the
computer and start grabbing things that
you want or controlling the computer or
whatever else
but
what you are trying to do then is take a
program and make it do something that it
wasn't intended to do
well
big sort of idea of computation is this
idea of universal computation that there
are programs
systems languages whatever you can take
a universal program and you can make it
do anything you want that's what it
means to be a universal program
universal computer universal language
whatever it's all the same kind of idea
so the question is as you go and type
extra crud into the buffer of a you know
of some program or something can you
somehow
manage to poke that program in such a
way that it becomes essentially a
universal program and or make use of the
fact that it already is a universal
program but you're now feeding it a
different program to run as its
as its piece of software so to speak
then and then that allows you to go
start taking over the rest of the
computer
so the problem is as everybody wants
everything to be smart everything has to
be a universal computer you know your
typical firewall that's trying to throw
out bad packets that are coming into
your computer system
that's definitely a universal computer
first of all it's running on a general
purpose computer but second of all even
at a software level it's got all kinds
of sophisticated things inside it it's
one of the things that's come out of my
science work is this principle of
computational equivalence that kind of
suggests that even systems of very
simple rules can be capable of
arbitrarily sophisticated computation in
particular universal computation and
that's why it's really unsurprising when
people say oh
you know by looking at you know css on
the web oh you can make a universal
computer out of that oh if you look at
this aspect of something on a blockchain
you can make a universal computer out of
that this doesn't surprise me at this
point you can make a universal computer
even out of extremely simple components
and so that's kind of the the the thing
that one tries to do in computer
security exploits is can one sort of
reach out of what the program was
supposed to do and into this kind of
universal zone
and then use that to take over a
computer well
i would say that um
uh
the um
the the earliest kind of internet
exploit so there are lots of exploits on
computers
directly at the computer so to speak
and people
the earliest internet exploit that i
think is known about is the morris worm
uh due to robert morris i remember
meeting uh well i was a consultant at
bell labs
for a while in the early 1980s and uh
um
robert morris's dad was a
computer security researcher actually at
bell labs i remember meeting the young
robert morris as teenager at some some
some party that at that time but anyway
subsequently this must have been
uh when was this this was late 1980s
um
the uh
uh
robert morris was i think a student at
cornell
and somehow managed to write a worm a
program that would go and infect other
go out on the internet infect computers
and replicate itself and then spread to
other computers and so on and so there
was this terrible moment i forget when
it was must have been 88 89 something
like that
um
when this worm was spreading over the
over the internet it was sort of the
first time a lot of people had heard of
well any of these issues of computer
security and so on and i we
were that time
we had been sort of early to the
internet we we uh you know we were
um
you know we had gotten our
domain
you know
140.177 that's our uh
uh
network uh address which we've had
forever um
but
one of the things that i was for some
reason aware of i can't even remember
why i was aware of this
the the whole issue of you know that the
internet might be sort of a vector
for computer security issues
and so one of the things i did was
there's a question of what would be the
gateway computer that we would put
that would connect from our computer
network out to the outside internet and
at that time we were making what was
then mathematica
run on all kinds of different computers
so we had computers arriving from all
over the world of people you know making
deals with us to port mathematica to run
on that particular kind of computer
and one of the slightly exotic computers
was sony had made a workstation computer
it's called the sony news computer
i don't know the news wasn't it was
spelled with a lowercase e and the other
ones were capitals i don't exactly know
what it stood for but in any case it was
a somewhat unusual computer let's say
and its operating system was in japanese
and
i for some reason had the i realized
that you know we should we could connect
to the internet with any gateway
computer we wanted and so we happened to
use that computer to connect to the the
internet because it was computer we had
around
and that turned out to be a really good
move because in those days and i think
it's still true
these different kinds of worms and
viruses and things they have to be
compiled for different kinds of
computers and they've been compiled at
that time for you know various kinds of
vaccis and some workstations and so on
but nobody had compiled a version the
worm had not been compiled for that sony
computer and so uh when it got to our um
uh you know our our connection to the
internet it was like uh i don't know
what to do here so it just ignored it
and so we were we were just fine and our
computers were not taken down by that uh
by that thing
but you know the thing that
is the case
people
have
a you know there's a whole
kind of strange
uh underworld
of people trying to find vulnerabilities
in software and there'd been all sorts
of efforts
to
take for example you know people have
sometimes said oh open source software
is going to be better because everybody
can find the vulnerabilities well the
the problem with that is both everybody
can find the vulnerabilities and
everybody can find the vulnerabilities
so um
it's uh
and there's a regular stream of
vulnerabilities found either by
governments
or by independent contractors or by
people who are essentially entrepreneurs
finding zero-day exploits exploits that
have never been done before um that can
be sold and what the going rate for one
is it used to be used to be 10 million
dollars i don't know what it is these
days um was sort of the going rate for a
zero-day exploit in some in some known
operating system and so on and so that
tends to be the the um you know somebody
finds these i don't know how
systematically they're found these days
i mean i certainly know that
uh for a while i was kind of um
uh avoiding
um
various kinds of methodologies that that
i think could probably systematically
find those things that come out of kind
of some of the science that i've done on
sort of exploring the computational
universe of possible programs but i
think probably i'm probably by now the
um the sophistication of efforts to find
those vulnerabilities have exceeded the
things that i had
imagined for doing that but that's sort
of the typical process
is somebody will find these by some kind
of you know oh you take something you
fuzz around the input you look at this
you look at that
um and
and then you know what happens to the
exploit is a whole different story of
whether it gets just uh reported the
public whether it gets
uh used by some military whether it gets
used by some
shady
outfit um
you know to to do something terrible and
so on it's um uh you know it it it
happens but i don't think
you know what i've seen
is
there are some times like the morris
worm where people sort of woke up to the
idea of of uh
security networks and so on i don't
think
that there's sort of huge um
uh effects
from it doesn't feel like you know it
feels like there are things like
bad things that happen in the world
plane crashes things you know
uh
thing crazy things people do
that you know once somebody did that
then
uh there's all kinds of protections that
get set up and everybody you know
has to take their shoes off going
through an airport security line or
something like this you know once
once that sort of hack was done once i i
would say that most of the time in
computer security exploits it's like
there's a piece of software it gets
patched it's like okay we're good now
there's a little bit of of kind of
paying attention to the supply chain of
software but i would say that there is
much from my observation as something of
an outsider there is much less systemic
you know oh my gosh this happened i mean
one common thing is people who use
random pieces of open source software
where it's like you know some random
person put that random javascript
library in somewhere and it's being
called by this it's been called by that
it's been called by that and oh well
somebody out there in the crowd the
amazing crowd uh you know makes a change
and by golly this giant chain of you
know half the javascript installations
in the world suddenly get this change
and oh whoops there was a bug in this
change whole thing comes crashing down
you know you would think that by the
time that it happened a few times
that uh that people would be kind of
wise to that issue but i i feel like it
hasn't as much been the case i mean it's
it's often an excuse to execute one of
the more common bait and switch
techniques for open source software of
yes there's a version that's out there
in the world but it isn't really secure
but we'll get to a much better secure
one and so on but i think it's um uh you
know i haven't i mean i have to say
there there are places
in
you know in medicine in
you know airplane disasters in
uh in military things where
you know people study
the problems
uh that occurred from the distant past
and you know people are still studying
battles that were fought in you know and
in ancient greek times and so on for for
like you know well don't make that
mistake or something when you fight a
battle today or whatever
it's not my impression that as much of
that is going on in computer security as
one might as one might think and that
there are a more kind of well we patched
that one we'll be okay let's go on until
the next one happens
i'm not sure but that's that's at least
my impression from the outside
all right i think we need to wrap up
here for today but thank you for some
interesting questions i see some more
saved up which we can address another
time
so
thanks very much